how are you doing good good jada pinka
smith makes her first public appearance
since her husband will smith slap chris
rock on the oscars stage
on saturday the 50-year-old actress
showed her support for grey's anatomy
creator shonda rhimes at the grand
opening of the rhymes performing arts
center in la
jada was all smiles looking stunning in
a gold strapless gown as she stood next
to shonda and debbie allen
the new venue will be home to the debbie
allen dance academy ahead of the event
the choreographer told et the space will
include an honorary studio named after
jada and will so this room over here
is the will and jada room
it's the room where we're going to teach
aerial arts
the cirque techniques yeah that's what
that is and they're preparing to do the
demonstration for today will and jada
have supported kids for a decade coming
to the hot chocolate nutcracker and so
much that they do for the community we
honor them with this studio but
look how good this is the parents can be
up here but they don't interrupt but
they can see their students their kids
are doing which is so important you know
there are so many food this is a rough
time for will especially but is a
reminder that they are doing things you
got to remember who people really are we
all make mistakes jada's appearance
comes one day after the academy
announced that will is banned from
attending any academy events in person
or virtually for 10 years in a statement
to et the king richard starr reacted to
the news writing i accept and respect
the academy's decision in an open letter
the president and ceo of the academy
explains will's ban and also expresses
deep gratitude to chris for maintaining
his composure under extraordinary
circumstances
even weeks following the infamous moment
post star billy porter still finds it
difficult to address it's a really rough
one for me
it's a really rough one for me you know
because
i don't know that i have the authority
to speak on it
but as a black queer man who has been
dragged through the mud for not being
masculine enough
in this world
you know
being called the cause of the
emasculation of the black man because i
decide to play with feminine silhouettes
in my clothing
it's really disheartening
that the version of masculinity shows up
like that
it's upsetting
it's upsetting and i will be
the black queen
that i am
because if that is the if that is the
representation of what masculinity is
supposed to be i don't need it
[Music]